[Music]
I like what you said there that you were
sort of even almost accidentally in a
way at first giving conservatives an
ability to be okay because they have
been under attack for so long so that
you gave them room to go right I'm not
so bad or I'm strongly not answer
whatever it is and I think in a weird
way I'm sort of maybe accidentally
partly and maybe not selected Ellie I've
given liberal some cover that are going
wait a minute something's wrong on the
left and I've just given them a little
bit of room to go it's okay to have some
conversation so I love that that we kind
of from different political places
different political homes the ideas of
just talking about ideas was was given
some room and as we said on my show I
I'm 100 percent certain that you and I
could sit down and over some more
ecstasy water we could probably we could
probably write a political platform that
eighty-five percent of the country get
mind I didn't solve we get behind
eighty-five percent of the people so so
that's a good segue dur to Cruz because
that you were a Cruz guy now I am I'm a
constitutional guy I want us to be
governed the way that the founding
fathers set up I believe in the branches
of government I don't like all the
executive actions people know my
thoughts on all of this stuff my feeling
with Cruz was there was something just
slimy about him like I couldn't and I
couldn't get over and I in retrospect
maybe I was wrong I don't know but I
couldn't get over that sort of used car
salesman thing with her with it with
with her with him now ironically we we
have come down so it is what it is but
in terms cause basically your guy like
that you thought this is the guy that is
defending all the principles that I
believe yeah there's a lot very over on
this very quickly of one one of the
reasons that I was a Ted Cruz fan was
because I've met Ted Cruz personally
before I ever saw him on TV
and I remember very distinctly thinking
this guy this would be early 2010-11
something like this I said I don't know
if this guy wants to be president but
he'll never do it because he's just too
nice he's just way too nice for this and
I thought Trump said that everybody
hated him
Senate President well I have no doubt
that they do but he's also studying
efficient principles and that's not
something the Senate's known for I guess
if I scented hater you're probably
probably a very good shave a but but I
really like them very much and and I had
a couple of contacts from them about
helping a little bit with the messaging
on the campaign and essentially I said
listen can we be crystal clear on this I
don't want to I don't want to be helping
to show you how Ted Cruz should be
acting on camera I want to be showing
you how to take Cruz should be not
acting on camera please please can we
not just go out there to his house and
spend an hour with the cameras rolling
and get all the official stuff out of
the way and get down to the guy who's
actually there and but I hear this for
many many many people and I never
particularly I could see it sometimes
yeah I could see it and my feeling was
well you you got a run right at this you
don't run away from those weaknesses you
got to run right towards it and get get
in front of it explain it but I liked I
liked a lot about about what Ted was say
I have to tell you the fact that Ted was
born in Canada bothered me enormous Lee
I mean but and this may be justification
but I think it's actual realistic
justification not to get too far on the
weeds with this but the requirement for
the president was a natural-born citizen
and the definition originally was that
you would be born in America exceptions
were made for people who were born
before we became independent for 50 60
years
but that you had to be born in the
United States or United States territory
of two American parents and the reason
was that they did not want an undue
influence on you in regard to one of the
countries and and now having spent so
much time with somebody from Russia I
certainly see things about the Russia
situation that I'd never seen before I
don't think it would influence me and my
ability to make a decision but it
certainly opened up things there now
what has absolutely influenced me and
prejudiced me I think is a fair way to
say it is that my mom is a British
subject and and I have a very strong
affinity to England my grandfather was
ordered the British Empire and so so
that aspect of it does bias me
and I can see that that was a reasonable
requirement now Barack Obama was not
there's no discussion about I'm not
going to get into a whole legality thing
obviously but he was not a natural-born
citizen by the definition of that
because no one's disputing that his
father was Kenyan when they ruled that
this was essentially okay when I said
okay where we he was not a natural-born
citizen by the by this genocide the
strict definition of it this the
original definition of it was to
American parents by the way I did a
quick little thing where I said let's
imagine a four-way race between Barack
Obama Arnold Schwarzenegger bill Whittle
and and Jesse Jackson which one of these
is qualified to be President it's Jesse
Jackson Barack Obama has a Kenyan father
I have a British mother Schwarzenegger
was born outside the country
according to the strict definition of it
now look it is what it is but when a
standard falls it's fallen you can't
unbreak it it sits down and it's like
the filibuster thing with the nuclear
option there was no Senate rules about
it it was it was comity which is
nowadays mostly comedy there it was
manners it was a gentleman's agreement
it was it was honor basically what it
was yeah we think it's important so this
is a tradition we've had for 150 200
years whatever Harry Reid decides they
need to vote so he uses the Harry Reid
option and it's gone and I do have many
supporters who say well we can't play
that way we got to hold ourselves to a
higher standard my response to that is
no no you cannot do that once you have
to fight the way you're being fought and
if that's the rules that they want
that's the rules that they got and
they're going to regret it
so there are videos a hundred percent
when I was on The Young Turks a
progressive network at the time when
they pulled the the nuclear option
direction what that the read option yeah
okay so what Harry did this and I was
saying that I was not for it because you
cannot change these rules and then
expect that it won't bite you in the ass
or something and I don't think they
expected it to bite them in the ass only
you know four years later or whatever it
is but yes you have to have principles
yeah it is hard to have principle yes
the point
that's exactly right great that one when
we were talking so much about the email
situation in the insecure the in secure
server anions appears area there's a
pretty nice machine really it wasn't
wasn't as beat up an old machine if they
couldn't was but but people would say to
me oh so you're telling me that if Ted
Cruz's have done the same thing you
would you would you would have a problem
if Ted Cruz had done that I want Ted
Cruz in jail I'd want him in jail more
than I want her in jail these are
standards and these are principles and
these don't change now you may not agree
with them but they're consistent for me
and they're important and if it turns
out that somebody who I've been
supporting has been breaking the law I
want that person in jail I want them in
jail more than I want somebody on the
other side in jail so does this all feed
to why you were so happy on election
night because of that as Andrew
described it the truck that ran through
the media or as I've described it the
the chess board that was thrown in the
air or whatever your metaphor is because
when the Democrats do some of this stuff
like crushing iPads with hammers and
bleach bidding computers things that the
Clinton campaign did or colluding with
Donna Brazile which was so obvious that
it was going to happen I had tweets
about why you CNN hiring her from back
in 2013
I'm not Kreskin over here you know it's
pretty obvious that these things were
happened so does that explain why you
were so happy that night because the
double standard categorically and that's
the only reason I was happy people that
I just I think we shouldn't diminish
that because it's so interesting you
were in a Crump guy I would suspect that
if you were if you're a real
constitutionalist as I expect you are
then you must have all sorts of fears
about Trump that you could you know take
too much power and too many executive
orders and look I'm not so much worried
about that to be honest with me my
primer my primary problems with Donald
Trump is I find him embarrassing there
are things he says and does that I find
embarrassing but that's the price that I
willingly and knowingly went into and
was prepared to pay now for those people
to think that Oh everybody all the
conservatives are always complaining
about the media bias just as a quick
point in 2014 Evan Thomas when he was a
managing editor at Newsweek said that he
thought that pressed by us in 2004 I
said 14 in 2004 he said he thought that
press bias for John Kerry and John
Edwards was worth 15 points at the poll
now that's John Kerry that's not Barack
Obama it's not Hillary Clinton so I took
a look at the electoral
College maps of 2008 2012 and 2016 I
took 15 points away from the Democrats
and the entire country is red Obama wins
Delaware and DC or something or he wins
why Hillary Hillary wins Delaware it's
all red all of it and as our just as a
rule of thumb that's how the country
would vote if the media was unbiased now
this needs to be said because I never
bring up the subject without saying it
many people think that I want a
conservative media I don't want a
conservative media I want a fair media
if we had a conservatively biased media
we would then fall into the exact same
errors that the Left falls into because
we have the ring of invisibility right
the ring your Star Wars guy I'm a Star
Trek guy but probably both love Lord of
the Rings and Andrew Craven pointed this
out what what the press bias does is it
gives Democratic politicians the ring of
invisibility they know they're not going
to get caught and so when people have a
sense of invisibility they do things
that they would never do otherwise and
this is why when sometimes in Mardi Gras
or something like that when people are
wearing masks they'll perform behaviors
that would never ever enter their minds
because they don't feel directly
responsible and this is the great
failure of the modern age is that I want
a press that is looking 24 hours a day
to find out whether there is impeachable
information on Donald Trump I want them
looking all the time constantly to see
if Donald Trump is colluding with the
Russians to see if he's impeachable
offenses are there but I would also like
that done for Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton and I don't want them to
suppress a story not just not cover it
just suppress it because then you've got
an autoimmune disease David you know if
it turns out that if it turns out that
the presses job is to go through the
human go through the political
bloodstream and and attack pathogens and
destroy them if it turns out that it's
not doing that but is in fact a way that
ideology and pathogens are coming into
the system you got countries got aims at
intellectual aids the mechanism designed
to defend us is now the mechanism that
is in fact bringing in the the contagion
is it too late to fix that have we
already crossed the threshold I think
you said I think I've quoted you on the
show actually you said that night
maybe maybe ice and now excited so many
times I'm not sure who said it but I own
a credit for that it got to parity that
night but the online media and the media
media got I honestly can't remember
which one of another
was it you I'll just you just assume it
was me all similar write very somebody
in this room fair that's food ran and if
I have said that publicly I'm pretty
sure credit is same for you fat but I
think it's probably just one of these
convergent thoughts you know where you
realize that some things happen so is it
too late to change it but there's good
news and bad news the good the bad news
is is it too late to change it yes yes
the good news is is it going to change
yes and I know that sounds paradoxical
the mainstream media and the entire
media complex and all of this is so
heavily invested now their pot committed
therein they've got to play this card -
they got to play the hand to the to the
end of the game and it is so massive
that you can't change it but the good
news is you don't have to because for
the first time it's not just our
civilizations collapse by the way I
started writing about the collapse of
civilization what kind of got me into it
is my love for history and I'll kept
wondering why do civilizations collapse
they there's a struggle struggle
struggle and when they finally reach
dominance you know when Rome finally
defeats Carthage and there's nothing
left and it should be pure off they go
they just collapsed and I think they
collapse because the elites get bored
but that's the first time in history
when common people have had the means to
actually influence other common people
in large numbers and circumvent not just
the priesthood of the of the churches or
the media or the politicians we just
talk directly with each other and that I
think is our saving grace because now
there's 160 million people walking
around with high-definition television
cameras in their pockets they've also
got news vans in their pockets that end
up the big mass in the big radio because
I can I can Facebook live an event and
now we're in the world of absolute truth
right once we get video we're out of the
world of what you think of what I think
there it is you know pics or it didn't
happen right I mean there it is
you can't you can't argue with seeing it
there is the inherent risk of that that
the system will have to fight back even
harder against us now with a lot of risk
it's it's the inevitable consequence of
yeah where do you see that going because
I
what I do worry about that data to more
that people that you know I find that I
can get more honest conversation at
listening to you or listening to Joe
Rogan or Phil DeFranco or sam Harris or
plenty of people that are you know
online people but and I turn on CNN I
mean I jokingly said to you in the green
room I put CNN on play because I know
you love bad room I got in there but I
watch it me and it seems like pure
dribble 18 heads all babbling on who got
everything wrong before the election now
telling you everything that's going to
happen six months from now at all of
this nonsense and it just seems it's
archaic and it's old machinery I mean
the amount of money that it costs
probably to do one night of Anderson
Cooper probably would foot the bill on
literally a year's worth of my show yeah
I don't think I'm being sarcasm not
about that so what do you fear that
monster sort of hitting back in whatever
that whatever that means to you it's
done the damage it's going to do it's
it's done the maximum amount of damage
it's going to do the world is changing
you can feel it in them
yeah taste it in the way or the water
whatever you had at the beginning of the
Lord of the Rings I got a chance to meet
a guy I like very much admire very much
named Mike Rowe and I'd love to get him
out of Joe he's a wonderful man he
really is and and he said I said I saw
one of these things that you just did
the way I heard it little he just sets
up a laptop in his in his kitchen and he
said yeah that thing got seven million
views or something when I was doing
deadliest jobs at my channel if I had
300,000 people watching a show I get I'd
get flowers from the network yeah so
here's why you know may be good just go
back to what you started with why why
are things so acrimonious I think
they're so acrimonious now because what
what is what is not being seen
underneath all the Trump Obama trip
Obama Hillary blahblah underneath all of
this way underneath it is human beings
are going through something that that's
only ever happened twice before in all
of human history we we are straddling a
a worldwide fundamental change in how
the world is built you could make the
case with so many wars and empires and
governments and so on kings and so on
battles that the only things that have
really happened in history is the
invention of agriculture the Industrial
Revolution of the Information Age and
when we talk about things like our
cities being these murder pits it's not
an easy problem to solve the reason the
cities are murder pitch is because the
jobs are going
the jobs are going is because America is
now fully in the Information Age and
industrial era jobs have gone to where
they're less expensive this is a
fundamental problem this is the same
problem that farmers had to face four
hundred years ago where farmers were
saying well we can't we can't feed
ourselves yeah you got to go work in a
factory in the city and they didn't want
to do that and and so it caused
tremendous upheaval but that's what
we're seeing it used to be that you
could that you could get off a boat and
walk through Ellis Island come out on
the other side and get a job in a
factory I mean no disrespect to factory
workers whatsoever but essentially an
assembly line job meant that your job is
to take this this this bolt and tighten
this bolt on in this location and
essentially anybody can do that anybody
so so industrial era jobs being
relatively repetitive gave people who
are hardworking and then oftentimes very
smart but people who were new here
people we needed a chance to get started
gave him a chance to do some work and
get some decent jobs out of it and
Baltimore for example Baltimore for a
brief period there the neighborhoods
were they were integrated they were
there were people who'd been there for
quite a while a lot of a lot of black
workers coming up from the south after
the war but everybody was working at the
factory everybody's working hard
everybody had a vested interest in
making their yard look nice everybody
was going to more or less the same
church as they were hanging out together
didn't last very long but it was there
and it was there because because the
economic opportunities were there and
it's not like some company decided hey
you know what we make more money in
China that isn't that in fact what
happens but it's it's a fundamental
enormous enormous change and you can't
get people into the information economy
as easily as you could get them into the
industrial economy it's interesting to
me because we're obviously go under
going something absolutely massive right
now addressable it's stressful yeah it's
stressful a lot of my direct messages
lately have been about that stress just
don't let politics make it crazy try to
escape and breve every now and again a
do some stuff you enjoy hopefully and
whatever else but it also shows why easy
answers are never the correct answer
remember because I was in Seattle last
week
and you know they've had this they push
for the $15 minimum wage all this time
and I cannot an economist but I
understand that I don't see why you
should be able to tell a private company
how much they should be able to pay
their employees bla bla bla I get off
the plane in Seattle and the McDonald's
in the Seattle Airport you know what
they have instead of workers they bought
about a kiosk a of iPad I assume I'll
have pretty soon we'll have hamburger
flippin machines yeah and that's because
this is I think this is the fundamental
difference between the two camps at we
call liberals and conservatives today
I'm sure that people going to find this
a self-serving explanation but
nevertheless here it is I believe that
liberals would rather feel good about
things even if they do harm and
conservatives would rather do things
that made sense even if it made them
look bad your example of the minimum
wage is a perfect example everybody
would like people to make $15 an hour
and and and it helped here we're free
I'd be in favor of free health care
right what kind of an animal would I be
no health care for you I don't like the
way you look your skin's a little dark
for me no health care for you off go off
and die in a ditch well I would be the
kind of person that people assume I am
if it were free but it's not free so
since it cost money we have to figure
out how to pay for it we have to figure
out how to pay for it means things like
competition all of a sudden you're
conservative again so this is the point
of it right it's it's you can feel good
about things because everybody else
tells you I'm in favor of I support but
I've got a bumper sticker on my Prius it
says Free Tibet see see how I like as I
care about Tibet and I'm deeply
concerned about the about the about the
people of Tibet
and I don't doubt that they are but if
you want a free to bed you need a bumper
sticker that says the United States
Marine Corps right or National Rifle
Association or something like that
because that's what it would take to
actually Free Tibet and that's not a
pleasant thought and nobody likes to
admit it and if you had somebody say
that you'd get a lot of grief for it but
it's the reality of the world and so
sugarcoating sugarcoating the outcome in
order to preserve this sense of this
warm fuzzy feeling I have about myself
to me is a form of vanity and hypocrisy
that I can't afford for myself
but we just as a society it seems to me
we don't have time for it anymore
because of the change that we're going
under right now there is no time to
fiddle around with these feeling things
when we're in such a massive time of uh
people right and we're in and and
wearing in this enormous of people here
I think this is probably the best way to
think about it why are people becoming
so why are the why are the sides
diverging so much why's that they can't
even we're not even looking at the same
news stories anymore why is it that half
the country thinks that Donald Trump
should be impeached immediately the
other half says that CNN's already
admitted there's nothing to this story
why why can't give the two sides here
each other and you know the the word
mean before the fort medic at would you
know impact the font at the bottom of it
Amin was it was the idea that a thought
could be transmitted the same way as a
gene could it could be passed on
essentially so I think you can get it
pretty good analogy out of genetics on
this if you have a population that lives
here and a significant number of people
move over there and now there's a
mountain range between them something
happens when everybody is living
together everybody inter marries and so
they said they share the exact same gene
pool when people go over to a second
location now these people have the same
gene pool is these people but if they
are no longer in a mingling with each
other the normal evolution that this
group has isn't affected by these guys
these guys have a whole nother set of
evolution and what you find is is you
find this genetic diversion and they'll
continue to divert and will divert until
they become different species because
they're because the genes are not
communicating
we're over here evolving they're over
here evolving and this split is
irrevocable unless you can remix the
populations I think it's the same thing
with means we basically here as
conservatives we hear news with your
stories we are interpretations all of it
that has become part of our mimetic code
and liberals have a memetic code too and
we're getting very close to the point
now where these two things Candida breed
anymore you know you comes a point when
the species diverged enough so that
that's the definition of a species is
one that can no longer interbreed with
the other right and this is bad this is
bad bad bad because even though this
divergence is happening so much we're
living next to each other you know these
these are not continents that are
going their separate ways we're
literally living it we in fact I'm in
the same room and yet here we are right
here we are the divergence is
essentially nothing it's it's
essentially nothing it's 10% 15% no
that's the part that I want to start
focusing on and I think maybe for the
next year of the show because I sense
the things are going to keep going like
this I'm going to try I think that's
what I've been trying to do anyway but
maybe focus a little more on that 10 or
15 percent because most of us want the
same simple thing if you know whether we
I am I suppose you're pro-life right you
know it's funny of all the things I am
I'm trying to pick me I am but of all of
the things in my in my toolbox that is
the one that's the most precarious
that's so interesting to me because I'm
pro-choice and I would say it with the
most begrudging unpleasant I just see no
option in this case that I you know we
can talk about how many months or you
know if you're going to know it somebody
have an abortion at some point then does
the state have to get involved in all
that stuff but even that that proves the
10% right there right you're saying I
jingly come to this or this I have like
I have fun I think the reason the
abortion issue is such a hot issue and
the reason that so many people do that
split go all the way to one side or all
the way to other because it does in fact
it leaves you without there's no middle
ground here mmm and and so you have to
pick one and if both sides of the
argument makes sense to you because they
do then you have to decide which one has
the greater weight right and I don't
have the religious belief that some
people do that that drives them to be
very very passionate about this and nor
do I have the complete lack of religious
belief that drives other people to be in
the other position this one is a tough
one the reason I come down on the
pro-life side is essentially pretty
simple people say this is my body I
should be able to right to control my
own body and I say you have 100 percent
agree with that but it's not your body
if this this is different this is an
entirely different chromosomal pattern
you could take a sample from the mother
and a sample from the infant and you
would get two completely different
people so frankly look the abortion
issue is very simple and get resolved in
one sentence it won't be resolved in one
sentence but it could be if you put all
the advertising terms away pro-life
project put all that stuff away what it
comes down to is
a person yes or no from conception to
birth is it a person if it's not a
person then who the hell are you to tell
me what to do with with my bodily
functions if it is a person then it has
protections that supersede somebody
else's opinion about it and that's where
the entire heart of the issue is is it a
person or not and the reason this thing
is so bloody hard is because there from
conception to birth there is no single
day or event that happens there's no
switch there's no there's no mile-marker
that gets passed it is a perfect
spectrum of absolute uniformity between
a cell that splits in half and a little
baby that comes crying into the world
and this is why this issues such a bear
right and that's why so some people will
argue well from conception its life and
then some people argue well at eight
months you should still be allowed to
have an abortion I would say both of
those are not great really tenable
position but then you know you can you
can widdle this no pun intended that me
all the time you must hear that means I
think like almost almost I get it like
17 times last week but but I would say
that may be all right if we could
whatever science could get us to where
we take all right for the first three
months you can have an abortion again
not because you love abortion I just
wanna have an abortion but we were
grudgingly allow for this tandem and I
know women I know two women in the last
year that had abortions who did not do
it lightly and the what a terrible
position to have to be put in even if
categorically yeah but but that's a okay
well for the first three months you can
ambition but then if the government then
says alright but if the magic moment
whatever you want to call it is three
months well now and we're not going to
let you have an abortion does this state
now have a responsibility now as a small
government guy and more of a libertarian
you probably don't want the state to
have responsibly but at the same time if
the state is saying you got to do it
then do we have responsibility I would
probably argue yes again but grudgingly
so that's why it's so but it's a rich
place to have a conversation rich
conversation tragic conversation there's
nobody in this discussion who's happy
about this no one's going to Lulu no no
I had an interesting thought about the
abortion issue because it got to me the
question of the whole person issue and
maybe this will help people who are who
are
who are on the pro-choice side
understand the pro-life position at
least understand it if not agree with it
does certainly not expected agree with
it at least understand it and and my
position my thought experiment was this
whose side were you on in the civil war
that what most people hate ignored as
was I 100% now the South claims that the
North launched this war of aggression
because they wanted to secede in state
rights and all that but the reason the
South left the Union was they wanted the
states rights and the state right was
the state right to have slaves so let's
just call it what it is they left before
link it was even inaugurated if you're a
southerner your position was this is my
property and they're going to launch a
war and come all the way down to my
house and take my property then of
course it's aggression of course I'm
going to fight it right the North's
position is the same position actually
as the pro-life crowd which is that is a
living person there and you do not own
them and you do not have a right to
determine their destiny therefore we
have a right to go down and free the
slaves we have them what not only a
right we have an obligation and so now
what you find out is that the motivation
of the Civil War comes down to a very
simple issue are slaves people yes or no
because if slaves are not people if
blacks from Africa are not people
they're not humans then they're property
like horses and cattle and so on the
North is absolutely wrong the words
completely unjust and so on but if they
are people then the North has the moral
right and the obligation to have the
government step in on that person's
individual choice and protect that
individual that's the fundamentals of
the pro-life position is that it is not
it is it has its own unique genetic code
it cannot defend itself it is no longer
subject to your choice it's a person and
when we're going to think we're going to
protect it is it a person isn't it how
do I know yeah we know conception we
know birth and that's all and because
the spectrum is uninterrupted we find
ourselves in this horrible conundrum
which puts me against my desire to
protect innocent lives that can't defend
themselves against the disgusting
repulsive idea that any institution
including the government
to tell you what to do and when to do it
yeah and that's why it's such a rich one
to talk about where where you can sit
across from somebody and hopefully not
impugn their every motive right right
and this is where the problem is right
everybody automatically demonizes the
other side automatically assumes they're
evil I suppose I've been guilty about to
some degree I try to focus that kind of
vitriol on people who I am convinced are
aware of what they're doing you know not
just people most all virtually all
liberals well I think many liberal
policies I consider to be very poor and
some of them I consider to be downright
evil but I will certainly grant that the
huge majority of people who support
these policies do so for fundamentally
good reasons they think it's the best
way to help people they think it's the
kind thing to do they think it's the
nice thing to do I don't question their
motives but the people that are
enforcing these policies know what the
consequences are in the real world and
those people have a problem if some arts
desire that you absolutely can't make
you're pretty good if I thought about
declaring the water here I'm like a cam
you know it's interesting I would be
remiss if I didn't say in the course of
all this a few times you've said
liberals and conservatives I think you
know I consider myself a classical
liberal so just for the sake of argument
when you say liberal really you're
talking about sort of a leftist or a
progressive yes just I hate to get lost
no no no labels are very very important
I know people will be commenting on
their design emeriti will talk about
liberal no no critically important I
meant to say progressives I usually do
here's the irony of it you you call
yourself a traditional liberal and I
call myself a conservative and what I'm
trying to conserve is liberal principles
I'm trying to conserve liberal
principles people think what when people
were being held as slaves I'm a liberal
when women are deprived from holding
office or deprived from from jobs that
you know the same pain of a I'm a
liberal I'm liberal on all these things
but when I become a conservative is when
this situation has gone too far you what
do you mean by too far when equality of
opportunity and equality under the law
and and when Martin Luther King says I
have a dream that my children will be
judged by not by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
I'm a big old liberal when it comes to
that but when you get to a place where
then you say things like wait that black
people can't be racist or that that we
need set asides or that we should hold
people to a lower standard or whatever
you've gone too far now I want to
conserve these principles I want to
conserve traditional liberalism
classical liberalism is not as what many
people on the far left would not agree
with today don't I know and free speech
is number one right for free speech
number one the fundamental idea of
classical liberalism is I should be able
to say whatever I dev will want to you
should be able to say whatever you'd mo
want to and you hurting my feelings is
not the same as assaulting me physically
it's my feelings getting hurt by you is
my problem not your problem and this is
a traditional core value of liberalism
which conservatives are trying to
conserve in the face of these
progressives who want people to shut up
and if they don't agree with them and
they hit him on the head with a tire
lock yeah and that's why I said
defending my liberal positions is
becoming a conservative principle it's
that Jack did say there we go so there
it is so most everything most everything
I think on the table politically could
be resolved amicably with things like
perhaps abortion being a real sticking
point emotionally but most things could
be I think resolved pretty amicably one
little example I was up in Idaho and I
was talking to some some people there
and it looks like they may be able to do
things as a state that we can't do as a
federal government and I said you know
guys if you could just explain the
Laffer curve you'd get what we want and
the and the progressive to get what they
want to if we could just show the math
that shows that there comes a point as
you lower the tax burden the economy
grows at such a rate that by lowering
taxes you increase revenue who loses
here businessmen and and people like me
and conservatives want lower taxes so we
can do more we can expand more we can do
and do all these other things but if it
turns out that lowering taxes increases
revenues and you're against that that's
where I go with these things I try to go
to the moral argument why do you need
poor people so much Democrats what do
you mean well your taxes are so high
that you're not getting maximum revenues
out of this economy so if you actually
genuinely believed you wanted to help
poor people and disadvantaged people you
need money to do it then you should be
in favor of something
brings in more revenues and if you're
saying no I'd rather let those people
undergo some hardship so long as the
rich get whacked now you don't have the
fig leaf anymore now you don't get to
say oh I'm doing this for somebody else
you're doing it out of a sense of envy
and and other venal writers I suspect
usually though that their argument be
well we want to take from these people
so that they can't get too much so that
we can you know they have another
justification for it I don't agree with
that justification this is one of the
instances taxes where I've definitely
shifted a little right in the last
couple years but I see where you're
pointing taxes look this is not a
inflammatory statement taxes are money
that are taken from individuals at a
rate determined by somebody else and
enforce by law I think we can all agree
on that's a relatively fair assessment
of it so so if your position is is some
people have too much other people don't
have enough I understand that position I
understand it I sympathize would be
would be and results that you're looking
for but if it turns out that your
personal animosity and your personal
commitment here's the thing if you
really believe that and it could be
shown that lowering taxes increases
state revenue than anybody that's not in
favor of that is not talking about
benefits for the poor they're talking
about their own envy they're talking
about their own inability to take your
eyes off of what somebody else is making
right and there's no end point I mean
there's no point where alright we've
taken enough now we can change the item
and do it more equitably right or so so
you know we hear you could take a look
at if you look at if you look at
education scores versus money what you
find is the more money we've spent the
worse our scores have gotten right and
it's all the arguments always the same
we need more money for schools where we
pay three or four times per student per
student more than the next closest
developed country and our grades are
27th 28th 29th people like me would look
at this and say it's not a question of
more money the more money we put in the
lower our result gets I would look at it
and say the problem of Education today
is we're getting what we're paying for
and we're not paying for education we're
paying for graduation and either
separate things we have a factory where
these boxes we get paid by the box that
comes out of the assembly line and it
doesn't matter if the product in the box
is a terrific product or if it's
broken or if there's nothing in the box
we get paid by the box oh that's what
we're paying for and that's what we're
going to get but if we decided we wanted
to start paying for education instead of
graduation we'd see a whole different
set of incentives and then people would
do what I think they normally do which
is pursue their best and self-interest
with in virtually everybody a sense of
understanding that I'm not the only
person in this entire country I have
obligations to other people for decency
and so on so you think people might be
fundamentally decent I know for an
absolute certain fact that if you and I
were to pick where to pick any ten
people from your audience of ten people
from my audience and put them in the
same room I would bet you it would take
us less than three hours to get people
to agree that all let's say ten and ten
yeah well 20 20 20 20 three of us 20 of
us could write up could write a plan for
that that we would in if we could get
past the animosity we would find here so
here in a nutshell here's the way I
think it works liberals have a desire to
protect people who are who are
underprivileged conservatives say yes
but the way to do that is is through
this mechanism and this is where that is
where the head goes but it goes this way
I personally I'm so offended by the
racist charge in the massagers charging
and the hateful charge in the Nazi
charge because it's not about I don't
care about them I just want as much as I
can get for me it turns out that the way
the world is built the way human nature
is built is that by me getting as much
as I can for me is in fact the best way
for these people to be helped this is
the this is the this is a difference
between feeling good and and seeing what
seems to be right many look if is
handing poor people money stop them from
being poor we wouldn't have poor people
wouldn't have poverty in this country
said trillions and trillions of dollars
have been paid and we're not getting
anywhere so it's not that so if it's not
that then what is it yeah all right well
we've done over an hour here now that I
know our studios are so close I suspect
we will do this
and we'll set up a couple hands with a
strap new we literally could have better
audio quality thing I have my studio
that is that close but I want to do one
thing and I didn't say the two words
common sense or you walked out of here
I'd feel bad because your book was the
common sense resistance it's the phrase
that your your tag on your website and
common sense I think nothing that we've
done here I think that for the most part
what I've consistently tried to do every
week is just bring a little common sense
sometimes I talk with pretty bright
people who are doing a really high-level
stuff that goes above that pay grade but
that the basics of what most people want
right now are common sense so to wrap
this on a nice little bow what is the
best way to just bring a little more
common sense into the world right now I
think common sense is derided by people
who have a vested interest in telling
themselves how important an we don't
edit for content no and the reason I
know this is because I was one of those
people myself you know if life was a
role-playing game I put all my points
into intelligence I just had to show
everybody how smart I was intelligence
was everything everything everything
didn't care about anything else but the
problem with that is it makes you think
that because you're smarter than people
in some area that you're smarter than
people in all areas and that's just not
true if you were to take I would suspect
that most progressives would think that
the way to handle something like the
economy would take the twenty brightest
Harvard Yale economist put them in a
room have them set policy and then this
policy would be determined across the
country legally enforced and that this
would be the smartest way to handle it
because they're smarter than the guy
that runs the gas station on the corner
of the street there's no question that
they're more intelligent and the guy
that runs the corner gas station but
what they don't know more about is how
to run the corner gas station and that's
what they don't know more about and the
idea that we are going to take away from
the person who runs the gas station the
decisions on how to run a gas station is
where we get into trouble just because
you're smarter than people in some areas
doesn't mean you're smarter than people
in all areas and kind of takes us back
to that gene your samples moment I had
where I thought well you know what what
what a cartoon of a you know of a rube
and then some grace I was just lightning
bolted into a realization of how
repugnant
that is and how much more this man must
know about many many things than I do
once you understand that you realize
that you can't take 10 or 20 processors
no matter how fast they are and process
information faster than you can with 320
million processors working in local
information in parallel all the time and
and so I think that the main thing to do
would be to get away from this sense of
is to get away from the sense that this
country consists of smart people and
dumb people and that the dumb people
vote for Donald Trump and that they
don't see you another the best thing I
ever heard about Donald Trump that goes
to this common-sense thing is I'm sure
you've heard this before so the
difference between progressives and
conservatives is that progressives take
Trump literally but they don't take him
seriously while conservatives
take them seriously but they don't take
it literally and that's really it we
know I know and most of us know what he
is this we tried a nice guy we tried a
couple of nice guys Mitt Romney's
probably the most piece of men ever
walked this earth in politics he's a
racist he's a murderer Easy's he's
giving people cancer he's sucking with
health care okay okay at the minder
fellow you want you want a nice fighter
you're going to get a knife fighter and
and so we can all walk it down and the
main reason I was so happy about coming
to do this was I knew this is what this
conversation was going to turn into it
was going to be an example the people
may have different labels in fact agree
on virtually everything and the things
that they don't agree on are things that
they can agree to disagree on I'm going
to go home and think about some of these
things probably in a way I hadn't before
and at the very least if you can't come
to agreement on this then you can at
least understand that the person who
you're disagreeing with is not some kind
of monster that's the essence of common
sense to me it's built into the society
it's baked in it's a texture that's
baked on the wall and we we we smeared
that at our peril
well let's keep this conversation go and
I'd be delighted
we will meet privately at that
restaurant I mentioned that sounds like
a lot of fun not at the exit that's a
dumb that I'm both probably have to
figure out an hour now for chin yeah I
think for chin now great what Chad
Nelson
don't be a theory and there's a good
restaurant within okay and fortune we
have to hold another discussion but yeah
they can say it was a good restaurant
it's just arrests not its poor Channel
have this ethical abortion is over it
all right
for more on bill check out bill Whittle
[Music]
you